my tummy's doing rumblies for sure I
feel like my ass could collapse at any
moment but I'm excited I'm just excited
my name's Lewis Capaldi I'm 25 years old
and today I am looking for the love of
my life I just look for kind eyes just a
charmer an absolute wizard in the
bedroom just uh sex machine
[Laughter]
hello hello there how you doing hello
Lisa for you oh thank you so much
they're beautiful how you look you look
so beautiful I just I feel a bit I feel
a bit underdressed you look you look
stunning honestly I I just I'm so glad
you're here I'm nervous I'm so sorry I
was as well so I've actually actually
been online and I've written down some
of the some of the best questions to ask
on Foster if you want me yeah let's do
it okay so um the first question they've
got here is what what do you look for in
a partner um
I think someone who's just loving caring
and yeah yeah you've got all those
activities honestly I'm so glad you said
that I could not agree more and someone
has just got a rocking board as well
that yeah and as I say just like someone
who can just do
when it comes to the bedroom just it's
not like a hit me on the headphones here
I hate to say it but you've literally
just described me and uh again I just
can't agree with you that's so crazy you
look like you can throw down yeah you
look like you've got a large penis but
it looks like it can do some damage it
does damage it does damage there's so
much damage as
um wash it down with a big cup of milk
slop actually I call it the the Nile
hauling of penises because he was the
yummiest member of One Direction for me
oh that is humorous and also true
but that's great would you like to try
the wine I would I wouldn't eat yeah
I'll try out
hmm thank you
oh yeah oh God I'm getting hints I'm
getting pissed
[Music]
you like you really know what you're
doing with your mouth
um
yeah oh spin it back out
that's fine
that's good thank you very much that's
lovely
cheers cheers to us
to love to love
that is wide
I just have a drink
yeah clean clean
so what do you think is your best treat
my best tree has got to be my absolute
big fat ass I got a lamps with dump
truck of an ass I would have said the
same thing as Boston Matt as Boston my
ass doobie Boston uh I get man on the
street shouting from my cousins and some
people might say that's uh or the Battle
of it if I may say so you do have an
absolute terrific
um rump and I I just happened to ask as
well what do you think my best out of
yours I think your best tree is probably
those lovely knuckles I know because
everyone says look yummy those look
absolutely scrumptious every scrumptious
is the exact word that yeah I can see
that surprise the real
um well they're 100
me babes uh okay if you can just excuse
me
I'll be here I'll be right here
[Music]
foreign
hello
[Music]
hello yes me
yeah no I think it's going really well
no yes it's absolutely
he's absolutely [ __ ] stunning he's
gorgeous he's gorgeous and I think we're
really gonna off he's got a lot to talk
a bit
um yeah no it's gone really really well
it's great so hot honestly
looks like it really really knows how to
[ __ ]
um anyway I better go because he's in
there on ego and they go back and see it
and see him he'll think about people
always okay all right I'll see you later
goodbye
sorry about that so sorry so sorry to
yourself box thing oh don't worry
honestly I was just I was just here
reeling from the conversation that's
been there titillating oh that's so good
to get so so they're obviously our best
best traits and I mean everyone can see
but what would you say your worst what
you asked I watched today as I'm
probably too I'm I'm too journalists of
a lover yeah I give too much I give too
much in the bedroom sometimes yeah you
are pretty quiet someone has to stop and
say hey
let's try you know but I just get up and
I give and I give and I give I'm a I'm
I'm I love to dash out pleasure the
problem with that is I also just
absolutely love
to give in the bedroom I'm also subject
well but two gavels make two levels do
good kettles make so profound beautiful
that's just another like from some of my
my art if you don't be asking why is
that the you you do I am a pretty uh I'm
pretty well uh sing a songwriter
um
oh yeah what do you have um read
anything that I'd be aware of
uh uh yes and probably um you may have
had a song called someone you love oh
wow yeah it's a big track
10 million records
how do I get into them I don't like
talking about myself that's the problem
although I was nominated programming I
didn't win though oh wow you're the real
price that stop it where you absolutely
start I mean I agree but um that's very
nice to use it better kind of
interesting but with all these hit
records and all these accolades you know
[Music]
um it also helps that I am riddled with
chlamydia any STDs just all of them I've
got the gamut great to hear oh herpes I
need to get help yeah I can pass it on
gotta catch them all gotta catch them
all Pokemon Vibes right I think that's
me too uh snap that's all right it
deleted the other but what would you say
like as your like main biggest sort of
guilty pleasure the wrestler the WWE I
don't don't watch it often but I
definitely still have a fond memory of
it when I was a child I went recently
to the WWE wrestling and there's nothing
I love more
than big bodily hairy man oiled
grabbing each other yes Russ where you
going Mr wriggles sorry about yes I just
love it the pageantry the little pants
everything about it are you describing I
love it are you describing the wrestling
or whatever we're going to be doing uh
well we'll definitely be wrestling
you can put me in the [ __ ] across
face anything you like
um should we just
should we just go here I would love
nothing more than to get out of here
that's it to you I have very good
closing sentence what's that
[Music]
when you got freaky with your lady well
way back in the days you're not put
cheese on the neck no no you told me you
did it's incompetent
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
better than Dwayne could roast Kevin one
two three no I'm gonna disagree I'm
going strong